hello and thank you for joining us for
this special global news presentation
i'm miranda anthosal february 6 2022
marks 70 years of queen elizabeth ii's
reign she is the first british monarch
to celebrate a platinum jubilee what a
celebration it will be events and
commemorations will take place
throughout the year including a massive
birthday parade and the lighting of
beacons we'll have more on what's
scheduled later on but first a look at
the road that brought us to this
historic milestone
elizabeth alexandra mary was born april
21st 1926. she was just a child when her
uncle king edward viii abdicated the
throne her father suddenly became king
and elizabeth was next in line i declare
before you all
with my whole life
whether it be long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great imperial
family to which we all belong
king george vi died of a heart attack on
february 6 1952 at the age of 56.
elizabeth was in kenya at the time and
at 25 years old her life was forever
changed when she was suddenly thrust
onto the throne
only a week ago she had left
lightheartedly as the princess
now it was the sad homecoming of a young
queen
the coordination of queen elizabeth ii
was over a year and a half later when on
june 2nd 1953
history was made
this was the first coronation ceremony
to be broadcast on television giving the
masses a glimpse at ancient royal
traditions her empire has shrunk over
time with more than 25 countries
declaring independence over the past 70
years others loosened their ties like
canada signing its constitution in 1982
there could be no better moment for me
as queen of canada
to declare again
my unbounded confidence
in the future of this wonderful country
her majesty's reign has spanned 14
british and 12 canadian prime ministers
and she has made 22 trips to canada the
most of any monarch behind the queen
three generations of future kings all
heirs to the british throne
seven decades on the throne as the queen
of england elizabeth ii has been a
long-standing symbol of strength and
tradition for many in britain and beyond
now to help further articulate the
influence and impact she's had during
her historic reign we're joined now by
dr andy mycock an expert in british
identity studies so andy queen elizabeth
ii is the longest reigning monarch in
british history as we all know but she
succeeded to the throne in a very
unconventional way when she became the
queen of england at just the age of 25
years old how prepared was she to do
this and how was she received by the
public
i think in many ways she spent all her
childhood being prepared
to become the monarch but she certainly
wasn't expecting her father to die so
young
and i think it was quite a traumatic
transition in many ways that she found
it very difficult at first
to take on the responsibility of being
the monarch but she certainly was
welcomed enthusiastically although there
was a significant amount of mourning
about her father she was a very popular
monarch and i think in many ways she
embodied that sense of britain coming
out of the second world war she was
young
and there's a certain sense of optimism
that she embodied that sense in which
she was a new kind of monarch and i
think in that sense
for many people as we come towards her
70th anniversary and
as as monarch i think people have lived
their lives with her i think she you
know in many ways she's been through
their lives and so people feel a very
strong connection to it in terms of the
fact that for most people in the united
kingdom they've lived most of their
lives with queen elizabeth ii as the
monarch
and of course britain's power on the
global stage has changed significantly
during her reign it's once vast empire
evolving into the commonwealth of
nations so andy take us through what
have been some of the key moments that
have really defined the queen's time on
the throne
well i think obviously the fact that she
came she came into it became monarch at
the point of their life when really
she wasn't expecting to she saw oversaw
the decline of the british empire in
many ways we saw that transition from
the british empire to the commonwealth
and in many ways that was a that was a
deeply affecting time for because of
course there's a very different kind of
molecule to that of her previous
monarchs but i think many of the things
that we've seen in terms of demarking
her uh
monarchy has been the sense in which
britain's changed over time as a country
it's become socially more multicultural
it's become a much more diverse country
and in many ways the traditions that
underpin the monarchy when she first
became malik has slowly changed over
time
but i think also that the relationship
between the british society and the
monarchies changed over time and it's a
very different kind of relationship
she's had to charter a period of
profound change and in that case i think
it's been one of the successes of the
monarchy under queen elizabeth ii that
it has managed to adapt to a country
that has changed huge
at the same time think that her
monarchy's been defined in many ways by
issues with the family and i think that
we can remember a lot of the challenges
that they had when princess diana died
but also the fact there's been you know
a certain amount of scandal around the
party with different members of the
royal family so i think she's found it
very difficult at times
to to marry the public relationship that
she has that public role with the fact
that times has been a very deeply
difficult time for her privately
absolutely you know 70 years with
everyone looking on at her the queen's
reign spanning seven decades and we know
that she's credited with trying to move
the monarchy into a more modern
direction but while also still
maintaining all those traditions so what
do you think and this is maybe a tough
question to answer but what do you think
will be her lasting legacy
i think a lasting legacy will be
numerous in many ways it'll be very much
tied to people's own sense of history
their own sense of identity
but in many ways she's maintained the
sense in which the monarchy is an
integral part of british life but also
part of the british constitution and
also the family of commonwealth nations
it's been a remarkable achievement in
many ways for her to maintain that sense
of which the monarchy has got a deep
sense of affection and popularity in
many countries i think one of the things
which is really notable is that although
there have been significant amounts of
challenges to the monarchy in many
different ways that over two-thirds of
the british public still very infirmary
in support of the monarchy so in that
sense i think that when people look back
they'll talk of an elizabethan age an
elizabethan age which spanned a huge
part of the 20th century and the 21st
century and that that elizabethan age
was in many ways one in a period that
people look back very fondly
and most certainly one to remember thank
you so much andy for your time today
thank you very much
queen elizabeth's 70 years on the throne
has not always been smooth sailing one
of her lowest points came during the 90s
after three of her children divorced or
separated from their spouses and a fire
gutted her windsor castle home she
referred to 1992 her 40th year on the
throne as anna's horribilis latin for
horrible year in 1997 following the
death of princess diana the queen at
first failed to join the public
outpouring of grief but she quickly
bowed to public pressure and delivered a
televised speech mourning the loss
now the royals may have put the
turbulence of the 90s behind them but
these last few years have presented
their own unique challenges for the
queen both at home and abroad and all
set against the backdrop of a global
pandemic now with more on this we're
joined by redmond shannon and our london
bureau so redmond through all the ups
and downs over the past 70 years of her
reign the queen had prince philip by her
side but with his passing last april
she'll mark this milestone without him
how does she seem to be dealing with
that
yes miranda well it just uh it bears uh
repeating of course they were married
for 73 years quite quite remarkable when
you think about it so obviously it's
going to have a huge personal impact on
her the queen doesn't talk much about
how she feels about things so it's hard
to know exactly but undoubtedly she will
be feeling that it's still less than a
year since he passed away last april
she has had health issues herself too
since then spending a rare night in
hospital in october also seen wearing or
using a cane
at an engagement in october but uh still
fulfilling engagements although
cancelling some after that hospital stay
she received people for engagements at
buckingham palace but perhaps she is
steadying herself for what will be this
big jubilee year ahead
and remin the queen has also lost in a
way her grandson prince harry you know
he's moved across the pond to los
angeles stepping down from royal duties
along with his wife former tv actress
meghan markle and all of this happening
less than two years into their marriage
harry megan then did that tell-all
interview on oprah while prince philip
was in the hospital this obviously came
as a big blow to the royals didn't it
yeah it certainly did i think
it is in a way you're right another loss
for the queen having harry so far away
moving initially of course to canada and
then down to california and it's uh
pretty much exactly two years since that
announcement from harry and megan to
move away from their royal duties and
just under a year since that was more or
less made permanent by the royal family
as you mentioned there was that tell-all
interview with oprah and harry really
cited two reasons from his point of view
why he wanted to do this first of all
the press he grew up in the spotlight of
the press with his mother diana of
course he said he saw the way things
were going in other words he didn't want
the same thing to happen to him and his
family and he mentioned a lack of
support from the firm the royal
establishment so that obviously would
have hurt the queen blind side of the
family in some regards harry losing his
military appointments and patronages
will certainly hurt him as a a veteran
of the afghan war
the queen of course saying in the
statement that she was saddened by his
move but perhaps she'll be most saddened
of all by what appears to be the falling
out between her two most prominent
grandsons the brothers william and harry
and it doesn't end there redmond the
latest crisis the queen has had to deal
with very much on a public stage as with
everything else is her son prince
andrews fall from grace so what kind of
impact is this having on the monarchy
well it's already had a large impact
obviously with andrew being stripped of
his titles quite recently
uh if this civil case uh lodged by uh
virginia du fray goes ahead in new york
this fall
this will be a media circus miranda it
will be hugely damaging to the royal
family if it does go ahead
one would imagine that ideally from a
royal family point of view this would be
settled outside court but perhaps that
is not what what virginia roberts dufrey
wants she wants to see
prince andrew face some sort of justice
from her point of view prince andrew
trying to defend himself from his
apparent friendship with uh sex
offenders jeffrey epstein and uh and
gillane maxwell
it's there's no good side to this for
the royal family and it has been and
will continue to be hugely damaging all
right remin very quickly i want to ask
you you know these challenges for the
queen go far beyond her family you know
with more and more countries questioning
their ties to the british monarchy and
whether or not it's still relevant so
what do you think this means for the
royals and their future
well they're still of course apart from
the uk are 14 more countries that are
realms including canada barbados leaving
last year and becoming a republic it's
quite difficult for a country like
canada to become a republic for various
reasons
australia tried to do it uh more than 20
years ago it failed the referendum
failed arguably a flawed process
according to some republicans new
zealand tried to do what canada did by
removing the union jack from its flag a
few years ago it couldn't do so so
there are
movements in many countries to move away
from the royal family but there are
still strong connections too and i think
that will continue to be the case at
least as long as queen elizabeth is on
the throne when charles arrives well
that's a different matter
alright redmond thank you so much for
your time today
the queen is no stranger to canada
making 22 visits during her reign she
took her first tour in 1951 when she was
princess elizabeth since then she has
traveled to all regions of the country
and has been a witness and active
participant in many historic events in
1982 the queen traveled to ottawa to
sign canada's constitution securing the
country's independence from britain her
most recent visit was in the summer of
2010. now with more on canada's
constitutional monarchy and what the
future may hold for this country's
relations with the crown we're joined
now by modern british historian marielle
grant so marielle this country has
always had a very strong relationship
with the united kingdom you know we
share a sovereign we're amongst the
oldest parliamentary democracies in the
world and many of our institutions and
systems are modeled on those of great
britain so tell us a little bit more
about what makes us a constitutional
monarchy
well the key thing that makes us a
constitutional monarchy is that the
queen is our head of state
and uh she is technically legally the
queen of canada and of course that's a
product of our colonial past and it
could be as we go forward in the future
as canadians we consider the legacy of
colonialism
we may at some point want to change that
relationship but it is as you said a
very long-standing relationship changing
it would be very very complicated
uh because it would require the
agreement of all the provinces to a
constitutional amendment and as well
there are many groups in this country
that actually have a very close uh
personal relationship with the crown uh
notably indigenous peoples who hold uh
treaty rights with the crown
and arguably there are strong benefits
to having a constitutional monarchy
because it means that we have a head of
state who is politically neutral who can
represent all of us at all times
regardless of our ethnic backgrounds
regardless of our political affiliations
and so arguably having a constitutional
monarchy has its benefits
and 70 years is a long time to be on the
throne how have canada crown relations
evolved over the decades since the queen
ascended to the throne back in 1952
well i think they've evolved in the
sense that
we are an important component of the
commonwealth and the queen has dedicated
most of her reign to
developing the commonwealth into an
institution that moves beyond and past
its colonial antecedents
obviously the queen has visited canada
more than any other country in the
commonwealth she sees herself as having
close bonds with this country and its
people
members of the royal family have served
as governor generals in the past in
canada i suppose the major change that's
taken place really over the course of
the 20th century into the 21st is that
the queen's representatives in canada
the governor generals and lieutenant
governors have now all been drawn from a
canadians or are all canadians what is
the the current role of the british
monarchy in canada then and what do you
think makes this country's bond with the
royals so unique
well obviously as i said a moment ago
we're in a constitutional monarchy so
the queen is our head of state and that
means that she represents all of us uh
on national occasions
she is the one who effectively is giving
out the medals
uh arguably this means that uh the
political leaders in our country uh have
obviously a very important political
role but they are not acting as head of
state
she is
and
she has played an important role in in
the past in terms of
advising um
what
for 12 canadian prime ministers over
time
she has participated in all sorts of
national
activities for example opening the
olympic games in montreal in 1976.
she was here of course to the
repatriation of the constitution in 1982
uh generally speaking uh from a
historical perspective she has tended to
generate a very positive response
uh very famously when she came to quebec
in in the 1960s there was a great deal
of protest and
they uh
people indicated that that when she was
driving through the streets they were
going to be turning their backs to the
uh
to the royal entourage and she was later
heard to comment that she noticed some
of them peeking over their shoulders to
have a look
now we are looking at a time where
people are questioning the relevance of
the monarchy in fact late last year the
government of barbados decided to remove
queen elizabeth ii as its head of state
officially becoming a republic within
the commonwealth so if you sort of
quickly sum up what do you think this
means for the future of canada's
relationship to the royals are we likely
to follow suit of what barbados did
be very very difficult for canada to
sever its relationship with the crown
and become a republic because in order
to do that there would have to be a
constitutional amendment and that would
require
the
consent of all of the provinces and as
well there are certain groups in this
country who have a very important
personal relationship with the crown
uh indigenous peoples who have treaty
rights with the crown and their views on
this would have to be taken into
consideration and one of the advantages
of constitutional monarchy is that we do
have a neutral head of state
interestingly barbados of course has uh
severed its uh constitutional
relationships with the crown at the same
time however barbados has chosen to
remain in the commonwealth of which the
queen is ahead so
this suggests that
uh its move towards uh republicanism is
obviously a reaction to the colonial
past in an attempt to move in another
direction
but uh
at a certain level they still want to
remain uh involved in the commonwealth
and retain some kind of relationship
with the queen
marielle thank you so much for your time
today we appreciate it
thank you
the queen's platinum jubilee marks the
70th anniversary of her accession to the
throne this impressive milestone never
before reached by any other british
monarch will be celebrated with all the
pomp and circumstance befitting a queen
now here to give us a breakdown of what
is being billed as a blockbuster tribute
is royal commentator richard
fitzwilliams he joins us now from london
so richard this is an extremely exciting
time but while february 6th is the
official date of the platinum jubilee
the celebrations won't actually take
place until this june so why is that why
do people have to wait for the
celebrations
the idea is the weather i would point
out i don't want this to appear dampener
but for the coronation in june 1953 it
was also chosen for the weather and it
poured but that didn't dampen people's
spirits because what was being
commemorated was so unique and it's
unique here because as you say
queen victoria had a diamond jubilee the
queen had that in 2012. now this is a
four day extravaganza
which commemorates something
absolutely unique but also there's so
many
fascinating mixed parts in this firstly
you've got what we always have the
beacons which are lit around the
commonwealth and in britain to
commemorate something that again is a
milestone these are beacons they date
back to the days of the spanish armada
where they were warning against invaders
now this of course is celebratory
also the queen's official birthday she
has two it's her prerogative and a
rather fascinating one the parade of
trooping the color which has
nearly 2 000
soldiers and musicians a fabulous
spectacle that kicks it off
all right amazing and the british
government richard has said that it is
promising a once in a generation show
that mixes really the best of british
ceremonial splendor with cutting-edge
technological displays now on top of all
of this you know we know that there's an
actual official metal that is designed
to mark each jubilee so do we know what
the platinum medal will look like and
who exactly is going to be awarded to
we know that the platinum medal is
likely to be awarded to those who've
given a certain level of service
including it has to be said some members
of the royal family i mean this is
something that
tends to be
given to those
particularly those in the armed forces
and of course their various the front
line the pandemic so forth that there
are those who always remember that this
occurred and the medal is there along
with the three previous jubilee medals
of course they tend to have this and the
medal that we've seen the coin uh has
the queen
is saluting or the queen in trooping
with trooping the color which was always
a very iconic image i mean the queen
with tripping the color which i
mentioned is going to be in the first
day the queen is in fact going to be
looking back on
trooping the color which basically go
back to the 1940s and until 1976 she
rode on a particular horse burmese which
was her favorite and she now has
attended the ceremony in queen victoria
satan and yes you're showing footage as
well from the diamond jubilee this is
the sort of weather we hope we don't get
it was the river pageant which linked to
that given for charles ii and what you
had here was of course the heavens
opening british plan taking over and the
weather absolutely pouring down on those
who were singing to celebrate the queen
what we hope we get in fine weather we
have as i mentioned trooping the color
and the beacons the first day and then
the second day we have the service of
thanksgiving
at some polls this has been a feature of
every jubilee and of course the queen
being deeply religious is or attaches
particular importance to this
and richard let me ask you very quickly
how does an occasion like the jubilee
and all its celebrations bring a nation
together what does it symbolize
especially in this moment in time
well what the symbolizes firstly is the
monarch as a symbol of national unity
and also it in the time of a pandemic
after two years of restrictions of one
sort or another the country is
absolutely dying to have something to
celebrate here you've got four days
you've got a big lunch and even a a
platinum jubilee pudding competition
which will be rather fantastic
and you also got pageants a pageant in
front of buckingham palace and you've
got as well you've got uh
concert there since brian mayne
the famous golden jubilee concert in
2002
who played god save the queen from the
roof of buckingham palace that was one
of the iconic images of the queen's jew
believes and since that i think they've
been tremendous interest in the idea of
a concert and it's more egalitarian than
the more formal commemorations equally
there's going to be and i mentioned the
love the idea of lunch and you mentioned
bringing people together there's going
to be the idea of reviving the street
party this was a feature of the 1977 so
that you believe which was absolutely
fantastic so with all the mix of all
these wonderful ingredients how could
the jubilee not be a fabulous success
and let's hope as well
don't let's forget
the derby the queen is one of the
world's equine experts she's won every
major race in britain but she has never
won the derby could this be the first
time a
platinum jubilee win for the monarch
who's won all the rest of them well it'd
be a perfect way to mark this impressive
milestone that definitely deserves a
celebration to remember thank you so
much richard for your insight today
a great pleasure
meantime here in canada the jubilee
celebrations will also take place across
the country in june the town criers
making proclamations and bagpipers
playing an anthem plus a commemorative
stamp and coin will be minted to honor
the queen and her historic reign that
concludes our special look at the
queen's platinum jubilee a major
milestone of modern history thank you
for joining us